(lively, bouncy music)
- When I realized that monuments of those
who served our country and
fought for the freedoms
that we enjoy today were in disrepair
and poor condition, uh, it upset me.
It's sad to see that they've
been forgotten, completely.
Most of them are unreadable,
so no one can tell
who they are, what they
did, and how they served
our country, and what
they meant to our country.
If you find a gleaming
stone that may be 100
or 150 years old, there's a good chance
that I've probably been there.
My name is Andrew Lumish, or better known
as The Good Cemeterian.
I restore the monuments
of veterans who served
in multiple conflicts for our
country and their families.
I complete restorations
on my day off typically,
which is Sunday.
I've restored between five
and 600 monuments to date.
Living in the South, there
is a multitude of things
that accumulate on a given stone.
It may have more than 100 years
of buildup and mildew and
mold, and it's very tedious,
it's very hard work,
soaking a stone with water,
scrubbing with brushes.
There are toothbrushes and Q-tips.
A monument restoration
typically will take between
two and four months, but there's nothing
that makes me feel as good as
when I complete a restoration.
The reason I began doing
this is for both personal
and historical reasons.
I have friends who serve
and friends who I lost
both in battle in combat, and
friends who lost their battle
once they came back home.
It's important to me to see
that they can be remembered
and not forgotten.
The monuments themselves
are not just stones.
I want to uncover who they
were as a human being,
as a person, in addition
to their sacrifice
and their service to our country,
because they weren't just soldiers either,
they were Americans first.
The were soldiers second.
I can't allow that to be forgotten.
(chiming)